guys it's time to talk about the future
of csgo eSports did valve just kill not
only what blasts Pro Series and ESL are
trying to do but any possibility that
will ever get anything like what League
of Legends and overwatch already have
and I gotta ask is this actually a good
thing
so about 48 hours ago valve dropped a
bombshell ruling on a number of issues
that we've been talking about in csgo
lately there were statements on media
rights for major broadcasts on shared
ownership and conflicts of interest and
on exclusive therefore franchised
competitive leagues literally the future
of csgo it's frankly hard to
over-exaggerate
how big of a ruling this could be and
what impact it could have on the future
of csgo so let me just read you the key
paragraph when it comes to the
exclusivity and franchising leagues then
recently there have been steps toward a
broad form of exclusivity where teams
who compete in a particular event are
restricted from attending another
operators events this form of team
exclusivity is an experiment that could
cause long-term damage in addition to
preventing other operators from
competing exclusivity prevents other
events from keeping the csgo ecosystem
functioning if an individual event fails
at this time we are not interested in
providing licenses for events that
restrict participating teams from
attending other events so this is big
like it's it's bigger than big and
there's a lot to talk about in this
video we're gonna go over how we got
here
why valve decided to speak out about
this issue at this particular time and
whether exclusivity and franchise
leagues are actually a good or a bad
thing and hey it's not just gonna be me
talking in this one we're also gonna
hear from broadcast talent Anders Blum
and the CEO of a straw Louis group okay
so why did valve come out with this
hardline statement now what prompted the
gaming world's most let a fair hands-off
publisher the deadbeat dad of eSports to
finally break the silence after all
there's been rumors and whispers for
years about a franchise League in csgo
but until recently that's all they've
been rumors and whispers and when I say
that obviously I'm talking about the
current era of eSports not CGS and stuff
that happened 15 years ago anyway over
the last let's say
one and a half to two years it's pretty
clear that csgo eSports have been
tilting inexorably towards a franchised
exclusive model to some degree that is a
model where a set group of teams play in
a structured league where there's no or
limited relegation and promotion there's
revenue sharing and obviously there's
exclusivity in that those teams can't go
and play for another league at the same
time there's also obviously degrees of
franchising between the black sort of
Wild West ideas and csgo to the white
city-based locked in overwatch model
anyways back to how this all started
first blast appears on the scene they
create not a league but a tournament
circuit where a set number of teams have
to attend a set number of events during
the year
there's also reportedly a revenue
sharing system in place and that in and
of itself is kind of already halfway
towards the kind of franchise leagues
that we're talking about except it lacks
one super important element and that is
explicit exclusivity also it should be
said that the sheer number of events
that blast has been hosting does create
a sort of pseudo exclusive situation
where teams like a straws for example
have to attend their events and thus
have to skip out on others flash forward
to earlier this month
ESL makes a big move they announce the
ESL Pro Tour
it's a system under which they take all
of their existing tournaments plus dream
hacks and push them together in a kind
of coherent circuit where rankings and
points matter and where they have two
championships per year at kind of ETA
and cologne fine that's that's great but
that's not the spicy part shortly after
that announcement eSports journalist
Jarek Lewis aka DK writing for Dec
cierto reported that apparently the ESL
pro league which is part of the Pro Tour
will have exclusivity provisions
according to DK the stipulation for pro
league is as follows quote beginning
January 1st 2020 all member teams of Pro
League shall not play in other
counter-strike leagues this means
valve sponsored competitions where the
first day of competition excluding
qualifiers and the grand final day are
more than 14 days apart
besides Pro League end quote this would
mean for example teams playing in pro
league next year wouldn't be able to
play in ECS then just last week blast
fired back and they announced something
called the blast premier the blast
premier is essentially a year long
league that split into two halves kind
of like League of Legends a spring and a
fall both have their own little
Championships and there's kind of a
global final at the end of it all where
by the way you can win a million bucks
so imagine a world and in a few months
you won't have to because it'll actually
happen where the valve majors compete
for prestige with two ESL championships
and a blast global final not to mention
the Intel Extreme Masters Grand Slam
if you thought figuring out whose era it
was or is now was difficult just wait
till next year and that finally catches
us up to today where valve dropped the
hammer and in no uncertain terms said no
to exclusivity now the first question I
have regarding this ruling is how
exclusive is too exclusive for valve it
seems pretty clear from the language of
the blog post that what ESL are
allegedly planning for their Pro League
probably ain't gonna happen
so what about blasts well nothing in the
blast premier announcements that I saw
at least mentioned exclusivity
explicitly but we know from this year's
blast Pro series that almost certainly
the teams that participate in the blast
premier will be predetermined at the
beginning of the year now before you
start typing your comment I know that
the promo video for the premiere flashed
the words qualify in multiple ways but
I'm certain that that refers to their
global finals not to being in the actual
league so even if and this is an if
blast premier does not explicitly
disqualify its teams from participating
in other events or tournaments the
intense schedule of the premier might
just do that on its own would that
exclusivity by default
let's call it meet the requirements for
valve to deny them a license to use csgo
the language in the blogpost is vague
enough to suggest it's a possibility and
if your blast right now that's pretty
[ __ ] scary next year in csgo is
already shaping up to be an incredibly
exciting one with ESL and blast maybe
among others competing for exclusivity
and eyeballs with this valve ruling I
have no idea what next year is gonna
look like because one thing is certain
both of these tournament organisers are
more than likely going to have to modify
their stated plans for their upcoming
circuits so now we've kind of talked
about how we got here and the house of
the situation so let's talk about the
wise
why is valve so concerned that they had
to come out and make this frankly
uncharacteristically hardline statement
to the public well let's take a really
quick really bird's-eye view at some of
the pros and some of the cons of
franchising in a csgo ecosystem now I
actually tweeted about this exact same
subject hours before valve made their
ruling which is frankly [ __ ]
incredible timing so thank you very much
gaben for that my point here is that a
lot of the responses I got on social
media were extremely negative towards
franchising the sentiment was if it
ain't broke don't fix it
but are you sure it's not broke we've
been in a space in csgo for frankly a
really long time now where there's just
too many events there's been too many
online leagues and there's been too many
LAN events ESL's overhaul of Pro League
with the land event replacing the online
League did help a bit but just look at
what happened earlier this year when the
likes of astrology and Team Liquid
decided that they had to start skipping
events it was a pretty bad scene for
certain TOS the reality is there has
only been more csgo to play every single
year every single month that's why we
had to have a player break
that's why certain teams are skipping
events and it's only going to continue
on this trajectory now I was just in
Berlin for the major mind you and I was
talking to the CEO of Astralis group
about this very subject you'll remember
that vast Rolla sandblaster now separate
and here's what he had to say I think
that the you know we certainly need we
need more structure in counter-strike
you know and you asked any of these
players any of these pro players here
they travel way too much yeah
they don't know where they're going next
you know well the next week they do but
you know a couple months forward
Australis has had really had a luxury of
being able to pick the tournament's that
they wanted to go to and you know not go
to two others an upcoming team doesn't
necessarily have that or even you know
even if you're just you know hovering
within the within the top ten so the
desaturation of events let's just call
it is one pro another is the
stabilization of storylines when you
read the press releases for the ESL pro
tour and for the blasts premiere
storylines was a word that came up a lot
they want to create a great fan
experience for people who are new to
csgo and people who've been watching
since 1.6 they wanted to be easy to
follow and they want to sell against it
let's be honest there's nothing wrong
with that are there no storylines of
currency ESCO no of course not but it
could be argued that a stabilized league
help creates longer-term stories that
payoff bigger in the end yeah speaking
of money there's one deceptively
important issue here that we should
touch on when it comes to prose and that
is attracting sponsorship and money now
to see us go have a sponsorship problem
as it stands from some perspectives
maybe but we seem to be doing all right
but the advantage of a more structured
league in theory is that people paying
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
of dollars into individual teams can
feel better about their investment
knowing that the team that they just
paid for travel for jerseys for
advertisements for won't get relegated
in a month or won't disappear and
dissolve because two guys on the roster
hate each other
the added stability brings in added
money and again this is something that
the CEO of astrologer pinda Klein Nyholm
told me in Berlin if you take something
like Origen sure we've been operating as
strong as before we knew what we were
doing we knew our sponsor
bass and so forth but we were out there
because the sponsors had a certainty of
astrology of origin participating in the
LEC and participating not just this
season but next season and the many next
seasons coming after that so so we
already were able to sign sponsors
before origin had played a single game
right you know
contrast that with Counter Strike you're
a new upcoming team where you're always
dreaming of being up there okay now for
the cons the part I know you've all been
waiting for number one does it limit
upward mobility of teams we love our
Cinderella stories and CS go look at a
vanguard at this latest major
talk about storylines right in a
structured lead where there's little or
no relegation we don't get that not only
that but you may risk including a
frankly uncompetitive team in your
league that makes things just less
exciting I'm kind of thinking of cloud 9
this year at the blast Pro Series also
while I was in Berlin I spoke to
legendary broadcast Hallett Anders Blum
and we talked about this exact subject
and for his part at least he thinks that
there is a potential solution out there
maybe we reset the teams in the league
at the start of every year maybe there's
a different buy-in structure or a
different qualification structure point
is he thinks it could be solved maybe
the solution is that if the rest of the
scene continues is normal then the
franchise League actually doesn't have
to worry about that it just says you
know what it's fine we'll just keep the
world we'll invite the people that we
think are the most qualified or have the
best you know business connection and I
think that's going to be important for
anyone like that the kinds of
organization that's going to be involved
probably I'm assuming will be someone
who understands you know the whole
business world at a higher level and can
bring something to the table in that
sense so and then the rest will have to
qualify over time like every year every
other year there'll be you know another
buying or another whatever it may be so
I can imagine that there is a solution
to that but sure it does kind of it does
fly a little bit in the face of the
current culture of Counter Strike the
other problem that everybody's talking
about is if we put all our eggs in one
basket and then we drop the basket what
kind of [ __ ] what I'm saying is if the
whole csgo eSports ecosystem invest in
one or two franchise leagues whether
it's ESL or blast or a valve one and
that League for whatever reason fails it
will have already killed all the other
competing TOS
and will be left with nothing the new
valve ruling clearly has this front of
mind saying quote we support experiments
that are scoped large enough to identify
new and interesting opportunities but
not so large than if they fail it would
be hard for the ecosystem to recover and
quote you probably won't be surprised to
hear that Andrews and myself also talked
about this this gay everything always
seems to be that well what happens if
you shoulder if you make it fifty
percent of the way there and during
those 50 percent you have competed
everybody else to even to make the
franchising happen and then it fails and
then you're back yo you're sort of
you're nowhere so if you eSports
historians out there might remember a
little organization called CGS which
back in the early 2000s crashed and
burned after sucking the lifeblood out
of other Tio's leaving us in a terrible
spot and setting back CS esports quite a
number of years and if you don't know
about it we have a video on it okay so
where do we stand
obviously this isn't a black and white
issue we don't explicitly know that
exclusive franchising would be a
terrible thing or would be the savior
for csgo eSports not that we need a
savior but I can't help but feel a
little I don't know disappointed that
Valve has decided to come in and
uncharacteristically make a hard-line
ruling that sort of kills some
possibilities in the future yes
entering into a world where csgo is
pseudo franchised and pseudo exclusive
at the very least is scary the unknown
is scary but that doesn't necessarily
mean it's a bad thing I am excited to
see where CS is gonna go just next year
let alone the next five or ten years but
if valve keeps coming in and cutting the
knees out from certain propositions like
this I don't know do we end up in a
period of stagnation do we get left
behind it's kind of a question I'm not
ready to answer but maybe you guys can
help me come to a conclusion all members
on my screen is so [ __ ] crack that is
so hard to read Wow
I dropped it in a bathroom in Berlin and
yeah it's [ __ ] what's that no he's my
hotel bathroom oh no no it wasn't it
would've got destroyed if it had been oh
I'll always remember Berlin now because
I can't read my phone